CBS News senior national security
contributor and former acting CIA
director Michael Morell has also joins
us at the table there is so much to
discuss Mike where to begin let's start
with the CIA analyst who says he went to
CIA first CIA says that they went then
went to the White House following policy
what policy is that I know of no policy
that would require the CIA to take that
whistleblower complaint to the White
House so you were surprised to hear that
yes the policy that I know of would say
since this is a potentially a crime the
CIA would have to report it to the
Department of Justice but not to the
White House not to the place where the
crime occurred right so I think the CIA
has some explaining to do what does it
suggest to you right it suggests to me
that people are protecting their
relationship with the White House and
that's the most important thing on their
mind here rather than getting to the
bottom of what happened well the
Department of Justice declined to look
into the allegations in the
whistleblowers complaint does Bill Bars
behavior on this raising the red flags
for you absolutely there are a lot of
questions about the Attorney General's
role here he dismissed these allegations
without conducting a preliminary
investigation he also played a central
role in blocking these allegations from
getting to Congress and while he has
denied that the president asked him to
reach out to the Ukraine the fact that
the president invoked his name in this
call multiple times it suggests that the
President believes he has an attorney
general who will help him protect him
and defend him something that he
believed repeatedly he has expressed
that he believed he was missing in
former attorney General Jeff Sessions
Mike the whistleblower says the
transcript of the phone call was put on
a different computer system is that
unusual what what is that system so the
system that the whistleblower is talking
about is in the intelligence Directorate
and the National Security Council staff
it is for the government's most
sensitive information it is where CIA
covert action information is kept this
summary of the conversation comes
nowhere close to needing to be on that
system why would they want it there the
whistleblower says to hide it the White
House says you have to explain why what
do you make of the president's comments
yesterday when he's talking about the
whistleblower he also uses a word spied
to describe the
people who were talking to the
whistleblower what did you make of that
it seems like a not so veiled threat the
whistleblower to me is a hero they had
the integrity to stand up and say I
think something is wrong
I think there's wrongdoing here I think
I need to report it and their hero
because they went through the right
channel right they could have gone to a
journalist and leaked it they didn't
they did the right thing it's a hero the
president is wrong does it matter to you
that the whistleblower allegedly has
political bias against the president
does that muddy the waters to you at all
so I think at some point the
whistleblower needs to come before
Congress and let the country see and let
the country hear from the whistleblower
and let both sides of Congress ask the
whistleblower questions will that put
his identity I mean I'm sorry will that
put will that put him or her at risk it
will but I think if you're going to try
the president right on these charges in
Congress the whistleblower has to come
public and has to be able to speak about
it publicly Paulo do you see that
happening that's for the whistleblower
well as Mike just said this person went
through the right channels they did the
right thing the whistleblower system is
designed to protect people from
retaliation losing their security
clearance or their job but based on
these comments we're hearing from the
president this concern is pretty
well-founded there the whistleblowers
attorney said their client is extremely
concerned about retaliation and now
we're worried that there may be a
chilling effect on other people coming
forward with allegations of misconduct
the New York Times called the
whistleblower CIA agent you also said
that last night on evening news what
makes you so sure about that when I read
the complaint yeah the complaint reads
to me like a high quality piece of CIA
analysis mmm the way it's structured you
know short paragraphs bullets the
precision of language the care in laying
out what you know and what you don't
know and how you learned it this was a
well trained analyst I'm kind of proud
of them and we should point out that the
whistleblowers description of the phone
call turned out to be dead-on right yep
all right Mike Morell thank you Mike and
Paula thank you too